hello folks how's everybody doing
I'm porch for me doing fine had an
operation on Thursday and my left leg
they killed one of my veins just a
superficial vein and I came out of it
alright there's always a danger because
they put you to sleep and you know
whenever they put you to sleep it's it's
a respectable situation anyways
hopefully I'll have better defenses next
time I get I have a bacteria like I had
September October anyways I want to
remind people that we have a conference
coming up in Lusaka that's in Zambia
country in Africa so if you want to have
a good adventure when you get to know
Africa if you've never been there well
here's your chance you'll be me some
great people ok so recommend that people
make plan to attend they can attend make
reservations in advance
ok ok I want to start with some persons
today that I received I received lots of
questions can't answer them all no way
and all I can do is remind people that
you know this site has a different
notion of what science is ok that's why
it's called rational science we're a
little different than mainstream science
and just about fact all other dissident
sites ok yeah we are dissidents we
disagree with the mainstream with the
official versions coming out of
mathematical physics we don't agree with
their version of science ok so we have a
different notion of what science is and
a lot of people you know they have this
impulsive common team they come in and
impulsively they say oh I'm gonna answer
that issue that he raised there and they
don't bother to take you know the time
to investigate what this
what this channel is about and you know
they they come in here and again it's
like impulsive commenting without
understanding and so you know I want to
kind of summarize real quickly what this
site is about gay why we're different
than the mainstream and the dissidents
out there yeah we're totally different
than all these people and you might say
well everybody says that no no we are
different you'll see in a second here
okay and here it is
these are this is a list of what we
consider not to be science okay and you
know if you were went to high school or
college you probably learn something
different you'll be shocked by what we
say is not part of sight we consider it
most of these things as part of religion
not science and so get ready if you know
hold on your seed if you've been
educated to believe these things are
part of science we're saying that
they're not none of them okay here goes
and none of these are part of science
okay
we don't use evidence in science we have
no use for evidence whatsoever we don't
prove we don't talk about truth we don't
talk about fact we consider all those
opinions dad we don't use equations math
or calculate none of that has anything
to do with science we do not use numbers
we do not use variables manifolds
mathematical objects we have no use of
none of that stuff that mathematical
physics uses okay just reading a comment
there anyways we don't use math math has
nothing to do with science nut math is
not the language of physics math has
absolutely nothing to do with anything
math is a language and as a language it
can only describe what it describes is
quantitatively and we have no use for it
because of the definition of science
science
national explanations you have to
explain a mechanism as it pertains to
physics right you have to explain a
mechanism and we have no use for
mathematics to explain a mechanism okay
so if you've been drilled to exhaustion
if you've been conditioned quotations
there to believe that mathematics is
part of science and we can't do without
mathematics here we wipe it all out
throw all the math books in the world in
the trashcan and you raise all the
equations we have no use whatsoever for
them math can only describe science as
it pertains to physics can needs to
explain you need to explain or a
mechanism you have to do it rationally
that's what this site is about okay it's
got to be rational what is rational
specifically there's several criteria
but the main one we can't move a concept
okay if you're moving concepts around
you're moving love around you know if
you juggle intelligence if you transmit
information then you're a religious
fanatic you have nothing to do with
science okay so we do not use the words
energy we do not use word for little
words such as mass or force or time no
four-letter words allow it here okay we
don't use concepts we do not move force
we do not move time we do not Bend time
we do not do anything with mass none of
that has anything to do with physical
interpretations of a you know a
mechanism okay so you need to understand
that before you put comments okay we do
not do any measurements we do not do
experiments science has nothing to do
with experiments in science we do not do
experiments in science we explain that
okay so we do not do experiments we do
not verify anything
we just create a theory that explains
what happened okay that's physics that's
science okay
no observers no testimony we don't do
observations people say we mean you know
through observations how can you how can
you even start if you have an observed a
phenomenon and so sometimes I need to
answer that question because you know
people are truly mistaken in the context
okay they're there they truly have a
problem understanding the Khans the
context of of one of what I mean when I
say that we we do not observe has any of
you observed the creation of the
universe has any of you ever observed
the creation of the earth or the Sun
that means we those things are out then
you want to observe evolution happening
are those not topics of science are we
not going to deal with them because we
have not observed them if something
happens on the other side of the
universe which we can't hear see touch
la blah blah smell it's not a perfect
science we cannot deal with that what we
do it in science we make an assumption
yeah you go to the blind man the blind
sage he cannot be a scientist because he
can't he hasn't observed so what we do
is we ask him look we give you a
hypothetical question say dear say dear
blind sage imagine another world on the
other side of the universe and this
thing happens over there can you explain
it and you tell us what the mechanism
would be for such an event and the sage
says okay come back tomorrow let me
think about it so he thinks about it he
hasn't observed anything it's a
hypothetical situation and he says look
this is the answer I give you this is
the mechanism I propose for that event I
mean it Stephen Hawking
ever
a black hole he's famous for black holes
right hopefully he never observed a
black hole he probably never even looked
through a telescope maybe he did some
time in his life I don't know but you
know you don't have to observe anything
you just have to hypothesize and put the
assumptions down and over those
assumptions build your theory we're
interested in the mechanism in the
theory okay
that's why observation has nothing to do
with science we don't gawk in science we
explain
that's why observation is not part of
science okay now knowing knowledge we
have no use for knowledge in science and
I'll get to that in a minute and I'll
cover that because there was another
comment we don't collect data and we
don't describe or just you know just
describe a chair that's that science we
say yeah chair has four legs a seat and
a backrest and maybe two armchair the
two you know the places to put the arms
so so the issue here is that you know a
lot of these issues that people bring up
like description and so on they have
nothing to do with science science is
not about just describing that the sky
is blue science is trying to explain
something why is it blue what's the
cause that it's blue okay so those are
the typical contexts okay the other
thing is again you know we don't use the
census any other five senses there's
only one sense and that's a sense of
touch everything every one of those
senses relies on touch
including sight but that's a long story
it's under the rope model that the sense
of sight is touch okay it's a long story
won't touch it today for sure we use
that other thing called the brain okay
that's what we use you got to think you
got a reason you got to make sense of a
mechanism and be able to tell to someone
that's it okay so that's science as far
as we're concerned in this site
you know a lot of these mathematicians
as we call they have this situation
where they say look here's a black hole
okay and it goes around and around the
star goes around and around the black
hole okay they say well what is a black
hole well it's a mass a big mass an
enormous mass of runaway mass that's
over there in the center and a star just
goes around it okay and we're not
interested in that because mass cannot
you can't see the mechanism there you
stare at that and the question is what
is the mechanism you know what are we
staring at we're we're just seeing a
star go around nothing in this case
there's something but when they look at
the night sky they never see a something
they just see darkness and they see a
star going around okay and the question
is you know can we just say and give you
a mechanism say mass does that it's a
runaway mass that's why that star is
going around nothing well by saying mass
we have not figured out what the
mechanism is you know the question is
what binds that star What's in between
the star in the black hole that's what
we want to understand unless you can
tell me what physical object lies
between the so-called black hole and
that star that's going around orbiting
around the center of mass we have no
mechanism and that's the issue the issue
is we need to figure out mechanisms and
physics okay
so that's what this site is about okay
we we need to do things with objects the
language of physics is illustration and
you need to illustrate you need to make
a movie of your mechanism in order for
us to follow your reasoning of how
mother nature could be doing hers
especially her invisible stuff out there
how does she do light how does he do
gravity how does she do magnetism
electricity the workings of the atom
those are the things we want to see and
we want to see it in a movie and for
that you need to put
objects you can't put energy in there
you can't put maths you can't put force
you can't put time we have no use for
those words because those are concepts
we can't say time did this and you know
energy did that that's not a that's not
physical interpretation and that's what
we're looking at mathematicians
dismissed that is philosophy they say
well that's that's philosophy we don't
we don't deal with that yeah because
they don't deal with them because they
can't explain how this universe works
but then they come into the qualitative
world and they purport to explain how
this universe works and they say they
inferred that or derive that or you know
so experiment and through math and
that's how they come up with this
nonsense as like black holes dark matter
big bang and all this other none since
they came up with in the last few years
so they they do cross over into the
qualitative word world when you say look
what you just told me is irrational they
say well that's that's philosophy
anyways what's important is math and you
can see that in all their papers if you
go to the literature what you'll find is
a lot of math a lot of equations you'll
never find a picture you won't find a
mechanism of how mother nature does her
you know runs her shop how father nature
run through this universe hey pop father
universe runs his universe yeah yeah so
this is the issue here we're interested
in mechanism who are interested in how
the universe works that's what we're
going to get it get to we figured out
all the visible stuff you know we know
how C saw worse we know how the window
broke you know brick went through the
window we know these things we can see
everything what we cannot see is the
magnet what's what's between two magnets
what we cannot see is gravity we let go
of the pen and the pen go it falls to
the floor we cannot see what did it
that's science that's where you have to
break your head and there's only one way
to do that and that's try to visualize
what medium what the mediator is in that
space and for those who say well there's
nothing there simply because you can't
see it or touch it well those are
deluded
individuals because they're they're
essentially doing it with spirits and
black magic there is something that you
can't see and you can't touch in that
space we just need to make it visible on
the screen that's how we're gonna
explain the mechanisms in this site yeah
okay anyways another comment this fall
talks about knowledge again we have no
use for nowadays if you would have
looked into this area he would have
saved himself the trouble of writing a
long comment I just took a portions of
it here your notions of knowledge and
predictions are confused oh okay
you can't know something in advance
because it implies that it has already
happened okay I know that okay
the future has per definition not
happened yet okay that's what I said so
what we say follows follow from causes
are just hypothesis we form from having
observed correlations very many times in
other words he says if your girl you
know loves candies you know that if you
put some candies on the table you know
when she comes home from school she's
gonna grab one of those candies and
sneak in steal it eat it whatever right
because you've seen it happen many times
you know it's it's like a habit that's
not knowledge that's uh it's called an
intelligent guess okay and that's what
he's talking about here
we can't know the same thing will happen
next time with absolute certainty I said
all of that as well so I don't know what
what his comment was or what his
objection was how he said that I'm
confused that's exactly what I said so I
don't know what he maybe he saw it
superficially I don't know but this is
my answer just in case for those who
wonder about the word knowledge now that
ability to predict the outcome of a
specific experiment without error well
we don't deal with predictions and we
don't deal with experiments and we don't
deal with knowledge in in rational
science so we don't have to worry about
that but I'm just defining it so that we
have a so whenever we use the word
knowledge we know what we're talking
about knowledge only deals with a
future knowledge is the same thing as
emissions for a specific instance for a
specific event for specific experiment
so it means you know every aspect of it
you know exactly what's gonna happen and
that's impossible okay because you don't
know if there's going to be an
earthquake that prevents you from
running your experiment you know if an
asteroid is gonna hit the earth and
break it into a million pieces you never
get the eggs to do your experiment so
all you have is an intelligent guess
yeah and today we haven't defined
knowledge we haven't defined this
justified true belief which is plato's
definition it's still in vogue okay and
that means knowledge is just belief
that's all it is officially and my
definition is up there you don't like it
you don't like either of these
definitions you have only a single
recourse and that's to define the word
knowledge so if you don't like these
definitions very simple you just have to
come up with a definition of your own
that fits your frame of mind whatever
okay okay and yeah and regarding the
issue came around because we have
omniscience a sight not to us we don't
know God is the guy who's who knows
everything or he or some people ascribe
that at the tribute you know that power
to God they say God knows everything
well if God knows everything if God is
omniscient okay that means he knows the
future because for him the future has
already happened because he's outside of
time because he's just all-knowing he is
everywhere he's every time okay so it's
a it's a super power we give to God and
the problem with that if you say that
God is omniscient whether he's outside
of time inside of time in the tenth time
mentioned we don't care none of that
matters if God knows exactly that I'm
gonna move my left hand next and my
right hand after that if he knows that
he already knew that in advance
I have no free will okay and I'm not
gonna deal with that anymore anyone who
says the operative is a deluded
individual there is no way to reconcile
a missions knowing the future with free
will
no way and they've been debating this
issue for 2,000 years obviously it takes
a little more than just saying oh yeah
very concealable no no if they've been
debating this issue for 2,000 years and
haven't figured it out you can go out
there and do your own research you'll
find out lots of people debating this
issue still and a lot of people trying
to religious people deluded individuals
trying to reconcile God can know
everything I still have free will no no
if God knows exactly what I'm gonna do
next if he knows what I'm thinking I
have no free will means the the future
has already happened all I'm doing is
walking on footsteps and I can't deal
with that anymore you know I mean it's
it's just straightforward for any
rational human being and I one of the
things I use here is here here I showed
us the other day I'll show it one more
time just to make sure and as Felix you
know I I made uh I didn't make it but I
make a movie okay does Felix have free
will he's an actor in a movie and no
matter what he does he's got to do the
same thing what I told them to do and
you might say well God doesn't tell us
what to do fine that's not the point the
point is here we have God in his in his
filing cabinet up there in heaven and
he's got your file he knows when you
were born and he knows already that you
died and he knows everything you did
between I mean if he's omniscient okay
now if he's he's just like us and
doesn't know the future doesn't matter
but if if God is omniscient it knows the
future he's got your files in that
cabinet okay and that means the future
has already happened if the future has
already happened you are not you do not
have free will just as simple as that if
you can't understand that we'll go see a
psychiatrist that's all I can tell you
and here's another comment and this one
related to vacuum of space love this one
Maxwell's electromagnetic theory finds
the vacuum of space as a medium
possessing at least two distinct
physical properties permittivity and
permeability this medium is the ether so
taking what he just wrote there we
defined the ether as equal to vacuum of
space plus two concepts one permittivity
one permeability that's what this
individual is saying well we have a
little bit of a problem because this
fella says vacuum is a medium for this
we need to define what a vacuum is and
what what a medium is and it turns out
that in rational science rational
individuals not be rational people but
rational individuals realize that
there's a difference between vacuum and
objects and things and medium or media
ok medium here let's define it just so
we all are on the same page it is right
next to the side-by-side so you can see
it medium that which has shape vacuum
that which doesn't have shape very
straightforward so vacuum is exactly the
opposite of the word medium medium is
the opposite of vacuum there antonyms ok
so when the person says vacuum is a
medium well all we can do is ask them to
define what a medium is what he means by
medium by vacuum and by space that's
just as simple as that
for us it's very straightforward either
it has shape or it doesn't and if it has
shape we call it an object thing entity
medium there's a lot of synonyms there
body substance and if it doesn't have
shape well it's a concept and one of
those concept is the word nothing and
that's what vacuum and space are the
space is absolutely nothing why because
it's it's got no shape there is no
medium there but all dissidents as well
as mainstreamers they all convert its
space into a physical object some into
the ether others into space-time you
know they they have all this what they
call vacuum energy etc in the background
now vacuum is
nothing means it's got no shape it's got
no matter in it itself if we take all
the matter out of the universe and we
have only space spaces nothing there is
nothing there okay
space is exactly nothing and it's very
difficult for people to wrap their heads
around there because we always talk in
terms of objects of media of things and
here we're talking about nothing nothing
nothing means the opposite of thing okay
another comment and this fellow says you
look he looked at this picture and he
says the pig has bore Satan he did not
claim that particles in QM exist uh-huh
I heard you said they they cannot be
visualized under certain under any
circumstances okay
did Bohr not back the existence of QM
particles well the issue is the word
exists here okay and the problem there
is that Bohr never defined it or or any
of his disables any his successor they
find the word exists so we had to define
this word because physics is the science
of existence and so you must define the
word exist for the purposes of physics
anyone talking about the existence of
something has crossed the line into
physics and Bohr never did that and so
we don't know what he means when he says
that a particle exists or doesn't exist
and that's the issue okay once we define
the word exist as object that has
location it's very simple either his
course particles have location or they
don't and that's up to him to determine
whether it meets that specification that
criteria okay so it's it's very
straightforward if something exists you
know it exists by definition not because
we believe there's no provision for
belief in the definition of exists it
just needs to meet the definition God
once they exist first he's got to be an
object it can't be a concept he can't be
loved he can't be intelligence God's got
to be an object he's got to have some
shape and then he's got to have location
and if God does not have location he
does not exist by definition
because we believe or stop believing or
whatever okay any more than my chair
disappears when I stop believing in it
maybe I disappear but not the chair okay
okay another comment and this is related
to particles which comes to the subject
matter we were gonna have today there
are no particles tell that to it because
that's what I used to said okay there
are no such things as particles tell
that to all the cloud chambers over the
past many decades tell that to the
particle collision results at the Large
Hadron Collider or other particle
accelerators that rely on ballistic
trajectories of the Sun things that we
call particles uh-huh some things okay
if there is a there really are no
particles theory it cannot be proven
again proof has nothing to do with
science probe means you swallow the
kool-aid
that's all proof means every time you
mention the word proof all you're saying
you believe because you swallow the
kool-aid you were hypnotized or whatever
you were conditioned somehow yet due to
our lack of measuring devices again we
don't measure anything in science guy
has nothing to do with that this is a
conceptual issue totally 150% you cannot
see particles or fields that's small no
observers in science
again all these failures to look at what
this site is about we don't we don't use
the eyes we don't use the senses we
don't use the sense of touch in any way
shape or form in science we use the mind
only we have to visualize mentally okay
very hard for people to understand that
because they think they got to go to the
lab run an experiment that do science
not at all the way you do science you
stay in your office you grab a beer okay
you sit back and you think you try to
visualize you try to explain how mother
nature's running this universe and if
you cannot do it with particles then you
got to dismiss the particles okay and he
continues to just wholesale say cog
chambers do not show paths of physical
particles or the LHC is not colliding
particles
without physical evidence again no
evidence in science I just don't think
it's a reasonable position okay because
he's relying on the 19th century really
it's the 17th century method of science
the scientific method that came from us
from the so called Scientific Revolution
of the 17th century we have no use for
that it's called religion ok we don't
use evidence we don't use experiments we
don't use math what we have to do is
explain a mechanism of how mother
nature's using her invisible objects to
do gravity light electricity magnetism
and so on okay and here's here's what
they show usually what you see out there
and they say see those are particles see
we've proven it well have we I mean what
you see there is supposedly according to
the people who do these experiments out
there in the accelerators what you're
looking at they're supposedly according
to them is an image particles that have
collided and so what you're seeing there
are traces let's get that right okay the
what you're staring at is supposed to a
an explosion of two particles in their
bubble or gas chambers right and which
are looking at those traces so what are
we talking about here we're saying that
these people are saying that they can
take a picture of a movie because those
traces are our verbs and the particle is
at the end of the trace and you're
saying oh they how did you take that
pinky took a snapshot of a trace of a
particle going through the gas chamber
making this trace in in wet a split
second well it turns out that these are
not photographs they're not pictures
they are reconstructions and they're
done electronically they're done through
algorithms and so on so you're not
staring at a photograph but
what they make you or that's what people
surmise it that's what they think
they're staring at you know and and the
questions whether those are traces those
are itineraries trajectories of
particles because you can see you can
still see the big explosion in the
center right well you know we have a
different version of that same thing
this is our atom right and it looks a
lot like that without having any
explosion or anything like that if you
have two of these atoms the rope model
of the atom
you haven't collide they would shake and
it would look more or less like what
these people are showing there so the
question is are those little tiny
particles or are we just banging two
atoms together that are made of you know
threads and ropes so you know it's not
the same thing to shoot a rock against
another Rock than to shake a spider's
web what we're saying they're shaking
the spider lips okay so we have a
different interpretation what they're
seeing in there and since they can't see
that they're making the assumption that
they're looking at particles and people
confuse the assumptions with proofs they
say oh they've proven it and proven
squat they haven't seen it they're just
making an assumption that they're
dealing with particles why because the
particle is not a particle that's why
particle is a number for a mathematician
for a particle mathematician all he's
doing is having values he's got values
called energy called mass called charge
so he's accelerating a so called charge
which is a concept he's accelerating if
he accelerates an electron he's
accelerating 1.6 times 10 to the 9 minus
19 coulombs that's what he's accelerant
he's accelerating of value how do you
how do you crash a number five against
the number four is there a way to do
that I mean I've never seen that but you
know maybe I'm wrong maybe you can crash
numbers but that's what they're doing
and so they in order to put a number on
their equation they have to treat it as
a unit which is what the so called
particle is supposed to be it's a value
that they can
an equation that's all that matters to
the mathematician this notion that
they're colliding corpuscles that's
what's wrong that's not what the quantum
mechanics are saying the corpuscle died
in the 19th century as soon as we got
into the first quarter of the 20th
century you got rid of corpuscles we
replace it with the word particle and
the word particle is very extremely
misleading especially for people who are
not familiar with quantum mechanics what
they're doing is not accelerating
corpuscles they're tell the early rating
values and until you get a grasp of that
that they're accelerating concepts
mathematical concepts and they're
squashing to Cod sub-state they're
squashing love against intelligence
that's what these people are doing or
love against love and people say oh
these they they bang two particles know
they they bang love against love they
didn't bang two hearts and people don't
understand that and until you really get
a graph so that that these people are
talking nonsense because they're talking
about concepts because they're trying to
make sense of the description not of an
X of a physical interpretation until you
get a grasp of that you know all these
pictures make no sense whatsoever
because they're show you a picture of
something real they say look we saw this
in a chamber the the in the gas that was
in the chamber so what was that trace
what we think it's a particle okay
what's a particle is it a little stone
oh no it's a value it's a charge it's a
bundle of energy
it's a wavefunction that's what they're
telling you and until you get a grasp of
you know get a feel for that you're lost
okay yeah so yeah it's very hard
sometimes to tell people this anywhere
we have authority I like to put on
thirty because people unfortunately rely
too much on Authority in here you have a
little bit about 30 and it's from these
gurus and here we have the first one mr.
Niels Bohr he says those who are not
shocked when they first come across
quantum theory cannot possibly have
studied so you think you understood
quantum mechanics it's because you
haven't yellow Susskind guy from Harvard
and Stanford so-called mathematical
physics of Stanford he says evolution
didn't equip us to be able to visualize
quantum mechanics evolution did this to
us and mr. Feynman who was Nobel Prize
what is its 1965 I think I can safely
say that nobody understands quantum
mechanics he's telling you in your face
and people can continue to insist no no
they understand them see because we have
all this technology you wouldn't have a
computer if it weren't for quantum
mechanics these guys are telling you in
your face in your face they don't
understand their own theory in other
words they cannot explain the mechanism
why because they're using concepts and
because they're using the particle and
you can't produce pull with particles so
they will never be able to understand it
under the quantum foundation the the the
assumptions of quantum mechanics says
directly Basking yourself if you can't
possibly avoid it but how can it be like
that nobody knows how it can be like
that with particles the more you see our
strange nature behaviors the harder it
is to make a model explains how even the
simplest phenomena actually work so
theoretical physics has given up on that
and of course they'll never explain it
with particles you have to be a deranged
Looney after 10,000 years to insist on
particles we've been doing particles now
ever since you know we can remember ever
since civilization if people explained
everything with particles photons and
later on they went to electrons and and
atoms and so on it was all particles we
cannot explain a bisti action at a
distance
pull with particles you have to put push
behind it you can't bring two things
together by throwing stones and and they
keep insisting because that's they can't
get away from that because all their
values that they put any in equation are
units they're like particle you know
condensed
convergence of whatever's that's the
problem
you can't explain with that and so yeah
here you have a a beam line maybe at the
Large Hadron Collider and you have a
reaccelerating particle or we exceed
accelerating little balls is that what's
being accelerated there or you know what
do you think Thomas Aquinas would say
you know because he might he might have
a different interpretation he might say
look what you're really accelerating our
angels okay because it's got all these
properties that we discussed the other
day okay
gives us an introduction to the subject
matter today and you know you might look
at that and say you know you're not
accelerating particles you're not
accelerating real balls which are
accelerating are angels and and he would
be right because essentially you know
the angels that we've been talking about
have all the same properties as
particles they could be at two places at
once
many of particles can be at one place at
the same time they can be anywhere so
that means they can go from one place to
another without going through the
intermediate space all those good at the
good properties that mr. Thomas Aquinas
attributed to angels who wrote a
treatise on us right are the same thing
that the quantum and mechanics have
applied to their particles all these
particles have magical super powers
because they can't see what's happening
in that invisible world and they will
never be able to explain it with
discrete particles the particle
hypothesis is what has to die anyone
who's still insisting today on particles
is a deranged Looney he needs to have
his head examined because after 10,000
years we should have figured out that
you can't simulate mother nature's
universe with particles you simply can't
not with discrete particles yeah and
people will twist and turn and say
whatever they want to say no you can't
okay you got a problem
if you insist on particles today and
yeah we do rail against particles and
that's really one of the big problem
okay let's get on to mr.
st. Thomas Aquinas and you know he says
he got his stuff from the Greeks and
then specifically from Euclid because
you could the guy who developed his
theory of geometry in other words he
wrote about it and he's that fellow
completely on the right over there in
the middle and the problem with that is
first that Euclid was probably not the
originator of all those theories all
these other fellows who came 300 years
200 years or 100 years before him
developed the theories or the notions of
geometry and what Euclid did was just
compile them put them together and wrote
his book elements which survives to this
day and he got all the credit
ok now you know and yeah yeah I've got
mr. Plato and some of you know this that
on the door of his academia ok
he had that inscription saying let no
one who this case that no one destitute
of geometry enter my doors and there's
different ways of saying a know how
people have said that over the years but
essentially geometry was around already
everybody from Persians to the Greeks to
the Gyptians the Indians all these
people knew about geometry they had to
because they had to measure the land for
one they had to build houses and they
built big pyramids you know I mean the
guy then know a little bit about
geometry about triangles about you know
this other stuff so you know this stuff
has been around for a long time you CLE
just kind of put it together and it's
commendable still you know but again he
he got it from all these other guys
what's the problem and how do we get to
aquinas with this well the issue is as
follows Euclid got it from for sure from
Aristotle who preceded him by probably
50 years no more than a hundred years
they were probably subsequent
generations one right after another
Euclid's from the 3rd century and
what is it breaking into the third
century Easter probably was born in the
fourth century BC and Aristotle he died
in the fourth century so so they were
they probably never met maybe you know
one guy died when the other guy was born
so to speak but when Aristotle died he
left his school and the school was the
Lyceum in Athens and lots of their
students in this school they wrote books
and they wrote stuff especially about
geometry and so on and they were
interested in physics that's the book
that's allegedly
Aristotle wrote and that survives to
this day and they wouldn't add interest
to someone geometry because it was well
known already Euclid probably
specialized in that but these guys are
interested in physics in general they
wanted to know how the universe works
and I think that's commendable because
that's the true nature of physics you
need to understand how mother nature
runs her shop that's the purpose of
physics and he who deviates from that is
not a physicist ok so the issue is they
would try to explain how this universe
works ok and that's what Aristotle
writes about in his eight books called
physics and so what did he talk about
well he brings in the particle I'm sorry
the the point and he brings in the line
ok from geometry and he's gonna use
those he's gonna use the point for
location and he's gonna use the light
specifically for continuity for anything
he wants to talk about continuous he use
it the line okay and the issue there is
that what do you mean contains what are
you talking about he's talking about
time talking about motion talking about
distance those are the things he's
talking at the number line okay these
are the things were they're gonna apply
the words line and point okay and so
this is where the duality of these words
comes in because the line you look and
you say what that that stick that's
there that's the line yeah but see that
represents distance or a display and
displacement or time or the
underlying the numbers okay and how
about the point well the point it's not
really a dot you know that's what's on
the picture but it represents the
location we had to put something at
location we put the dot to market so the
issue is not that Aristotle or his
disciplines used it for 40 amma tree
they wanted to figure out how the
universe works how mother nature runs
her shop for this they had to talk about
distance about motion about time and of
course they brought in mathematics and
they were talking about numbers
specifically the number line and so this
is where all these issues come in okay
and what happens with Thomas Aquinas he
comes in 1500 years later and he uses
not only the Greeks but some other
people from about 700 years before him
like bow shoes and so on and he uses
their their notions and he tries to
figure out especially what concerns him
and that's whether the issue of
omniscience whether God is omniscient
and if he's a mission do we have free
will and so he talks a lot about in his
theory about free will and he also has
to introduce what was popular those days
which is angels okay and so we started
talking about the Angels the other day
and this is what he puts up there baby
this is st. Thomas Aquinas okay he's got
all these questions that he's asking
okay and it turns out that these
questions resemble pretty much what
quantum mechanics has today the in fact
the issues are almost exactly alike
st. Thomas asks whether an Angels
altogether incorporeal and today we
asked the same question in quantum
whether particles altogether incorporeal
is that a concept is that an object are
we talking about a corpuscle what is a
particle and then st. Thomas will say
okay and angels composed of matter in
form yes or no do they exist in great
numbers with a different species are
there different kinds of angels you know
is that does an angel have location
in a place can it be can now an angel be
in two places at once and so I'm down
the line and you can see they match
exactly with the issues that come up
with quantum
you know eight hundred nine hundred
years later and so these are the issues
that we started talking about the other
day and the first two we covered the
altogether incorporeal in the matter and
form let's look at a couple of the
others today says angels exist in great
numbers do they exist in great numbers
do particles exist in great numbers okay
this is the the issue that we're going
to start with trying to answer those
questions so here's um there's good ol
st. Thomas and this is what he writes
about this in general I mean I pulled
the the main points from his
dissertation whether the angels exist in
great number and he says there there
have been various opinions with regard
to the number of the separate substances
and he gets this from Aristotle he II
harps a lot on what he calls the
Philosopher's the Philosopher's okay it
is not true that the immaterial
substances exist on account of the
corporeal okay so that means that and
he's talking about angels there okay the
end material substances that's the guys
that are there between God and us and
they're the mediators okay kind of like
the particles at the CERN and slack the
multiplication of the angels is not to
be taken according to matter nor
according to bodies but according to the
divine wisdom devising the various
orders of in material substances guess
who that is that's mister God the man
upstairs himself and so continues he
says in the Angels number is not that of
discrete quantity you can't count angels
because see he switches back and forth
between a and angel which you can
imagine with feathers and you know ring
on top of his head that's an object and
the concept the fact that angel
represents a soul the mind so he goes
back and forth with this and throughout
his his whole thing
Treatise okay says so he says in the
Angels number is not that of discrete
quantity okay they're continuous so to
speak because he's again talking about
concepts brought about by division of
what is continuous but that which is but
that which is caused by distinction of
forms okay and so what's uh fours answer
to that you know here it is see if we
can put it up here he says the entire
universe may well be infinite extent
these are his discipline this doesn't
come directly from Bohr but it doesn't
matter because they all have the same
notion the entire universe may well be
infinite in extent time and these are
different statements from people okay
today and these are all you can say
formal notions that people have these
are PhDs that write these things time is
infinite but space is not another
opinion and then you'll see that article
there came out of popular astronomy but
it was quoting was it it was quoting
some other article but it doesn't matter
now this comes from popular strata says
barring its definition and nature
constantly and unswervingly in mind we
may affirm with utmost confidence and
positive positiveness that both space
and time are truly infinite so you have
all these different opinions
it could be infinite one is infinite the
other one is not the other guy said yeah
it's truly infinite we have proved it
yeah
and what is an event an event is for
general relativity is the instantaneous
physical situation or appearance
associated with a point in space-time
that famous word point so we have what
is a point point is a dot right no it's
not it's a location what do you mean a
location it's a location where something
happened how can something happen at a
point how can how can you identify the
word event which is a verb
with a noun such as the dot or location
or whatever in other words it's a static
concept dot or location is a static
concept event as a dynamic one it's a
verb that's what an event is we've
turned the event into a noun but event
is a verb event means something is
happening you can't you can't have an
event on a single frame of the movie you
need at least two frames of a movie to
see an event okay and what they've done
is they condense that movie into a dot
into a location okay that's what they've
done and then the question is you know
they say space-time is made out of all
these events all these dots that make up
space-time they talk about the
quantization of space-time made of dots
and then they tell you that space and
time are infinite therefore we have
innumerable infinite incessant County of
dots of points of events and if that's
the case well uh no different than what
mr. Aquinas was saying you know you know
you don't have a fixed quantity of
angels of particles of dots you have an
infinite quantity of them because
space-time is infinite supposedly and
again they haven't decided whether it's
infinite or not they they keep rolling
around in circles whether space and time
are infinite and they'll be going around
in circles for the next hundred years or
until extinction yeah okay here's
another the second issue that st. Thomas
brings up and that's whether the angels
different species are there different
kinds of angels and I think there are if
you go into his mind because he says you
know there are good angels and bad
angels you have these devils and they're
angels too but they're dark angels their
meaning to the red angels maybe I don't
know they come from the south not from
the north okay the good of the species
preponderance over the good of the
uh-huh so we're talking about a species
versus the individual who comprises a
species okay because he's he's
categorizing these things he gets all
these categories from Aristotle by the
way okay
hence it is much better for the species
to be multiplied in the Angels than for
individuals to be multiplied in in in
the one species the perfection of the
angelic nature calls for the multiplying
of species but not for the multiplying
of individuals in one species so he says
species be nice to have many it's good
for the universe but with any species
not good that we have too many that
unlimited you know within within each
group yeah that's his notion what does
Niels Bohr say and his people today
regarding that well what they produced
is the standard model of quantum
mechanics and it looks something like
that these are the species the types of
particles okay and so they're not
infinite like st. Thomas's angel okay
but it turns out that these are the
primary ones these particles you know
they they become like today they say
there's like 200 particles at least they
have phonons which are not included in
there they have tachyons they created
all these particles you know solitons
and so on they created a lot of
particles which they need to explain
certain things so they gave names to
lots of particles that are not in that
in the standard model okay but so so how
many species are there well what a
mechanics predicts to use that term they
like that word predicts so I'll use the
word predict that is so famous in
mathematical physics quantum mechanics
predicts a fundamental elementary
particle it predicts it and you say well
what should go to the lab and smash the
particles and find out no we don't do
experiments in science remember starting
point today we don't do experiments we
don't go to
scientists don't go to the lab that's
for Gophers we send a technician say do
this experiment for me
bring me the results and I'm gonna do
the thinking that's the way it works the
scientist is the guy that's upstairs not
the guy that's in the lab never does a
scientist stuff in a lab okay if it's in
the lab he's not a scientist he's a
gopher so so the question is why do we
do we need to run an experiment no we
don't need to run any expand this is a
conceptual issue strictly conceptual you
smash particles you get more particles
now you smash those tinier particles you
get more particles you can't continue
smashing or dividing particles as mr.
Democritus and loose if is's boss or
teacher constructor said hundreds of
years ago
you can't continues smashing them and
arrive at nothing you can smash a
particle cut it in half in four pieces
and 10-piece any amount of time you want
any any number of pieces you want you'll
never end up with nothing
you always at the end will end up with
something this is a totally a conceptual
issue I don't need to go to the lab I
don't need to study mathematics or this
not all I need to know is conceptualize
it I can't break something something
that has shape and end up with something
that doesn't have shape with nothing
okay so if I cut and cut and cut and cut
and cut I will finally end up with
something quantum mechanics predicts an
ultimate elementary fundamental particle
okay and that's the particle that should
be called the elementary fundamental
particle that makes everything else
assuming there's only what well we're
just gonna make that a sound could be
two it could be three fight but
different species right like st. Thomas
says here but if we assume that there's
one there's gonna be at least one guy
that we can't have none we have to have
at least one if there's one that's the
one we're gonna call the fundamental
elementary particle and we don't need to
smash it me and we can't ask well what
is it made out of it can't be made
of anything because it's the elementary
fundamental particle that's why that's
the name that's by definition it's where
the buck stops okay buck stops here and
so you can't continue smashing particles
and always come up with more particles
and say I'm just gonna name them and get
my Nobel Prize doesn't work you gotta
sit back say there's got to be a
fundamental particle that comprises
everything else if if that's the case
but it has to be the case that at least
there is one ultimate particle in the
universe because you can't keep chopping
matter into pieces and arrive at
absolutely nothing so quantum mechanics
because of its assumptions the particle
assumptions has to have a fundamental
elementary particle okay and so to
answer mr. st. Thomas quantum mechanics
is answer to that is there's only one
particle ultimately at least one part
okay maybe there's two or three I don't
know fundamental particles they're a
little different for whatever reason one
can cannot imagine but for sure there's
at least one and this is not a question
of chopping them up okay and I'm sure
that if we had God's eyes and and there
were particles out there which we say
here there aren't we should arrive at a
single particle and that particle that's
the one that received the name of
fundamental particle okay here's another
comment from oh no this this is another
issue with the particle I showed the
other day where we have the particles
come in from the boy okay so we have the
virtual particle which is a particle
that comes into being when the
mathematician needs it and so the
question is you know are these particles
are these fundamental particles can we
chop these up and come up with more
virtual particles do they comprise the
vacuum that forms a backdrop to matter
you know they have these these know
out there and that they've created again
these are not particles they're concepts
but they created all this because they
have no explanation for how mother
nature does runs her shop and so they
had to create all this nonsense of
virtual particles and quasi particles
that come in from the void and then they
go back into the void and comprise the
void they had to do all this okay here
we have another one from mr. Saint
Thomas Aquinas and he says the following
he says whether an angel can be in
several places at once
certainly sounds a lot like quantum
mechanics doesn't end right we've had
that notion of particles being in
several places at once
says an Angels power of nature are
finite whereas the divine power in
essence is infinite consequently God is
not merely present in some places but is
everywhere okay and it sounds a lot like
the particles that we're going to see in
a minute here okay some suppose the
individuos indivisibility of the angel
to be like that of a point again he's
referring to location and after the dot
because the dot is divisible it's the
location which is not divisible so he
says some suppose that that the angel
was like a point meaning location let's
keep the words property in the proper
context okay
consequently they thought that an angel
could be only in a place which is a
point again location the use of the word
point is third I don't have uses the
word dot for he but he means location he
doesn't mean the geometric point meaning
the thought okay that that is always put
in the start of geometry but they were
manifestly deceived because a point is
something indivisible dot is divisible
what's not divisible is location okay
yet having its situation yeah meaning
location that's where he mentions
essentially that he's talking about
location when he says yet
having a situation where as if the
Angels is indivisible and Beyond a genus
of quantity and situation meaning place
meaning location okay so he says that
the dot the point is not like an angel
because the point cannot be divided but
it's it has location meaning the
location has location whereas an angel
can be you know cannot be but it is
individual cannot be divided but an
angel has no location that's where
differs from the point okay it is
evident that to be in a place a pertains
quite differently to a body okay to an
angel and to God a body is in a place in
a circumscribed fashion since it is
measured by the place an angel is not
measured by the place he is in one place
in such a manner that he is not in
another so an angel apparently can only
be in one place or another right
but God to need is neither
circumscription me nor definitely there
because he is everywhere and you know
what does uh go to uh Niels Bohr and his
people say to that well here it is this
is their answer from today quantum
coherence from the Wikipedia in Young's
double-slit experiment electrons can be
used in the place of light waves talking
about ways each electrons wavefunction
goes through both slits in the slit
experiment for those of you who are
familiar with it what is he talking
about well fortunately we have a what is
it a a little movie by dr. quantum and
he illustrates this here it is okay with
this quantum show well he shows that
you'll see it here in a minute when it
starts again the particle starts out
from a gun and in this case it's an
electron and it's going to be shot out
okay to the slits but only one particle
at a time
turns out the particle is at two places
at once it's at both slits
simultaneously and dr. quantum cannot
figure it out using what the hell and
here you can see the particle is at two
places at once okay and then it kind of
super imposes on itself on a
superposition and that's how it's gonna
create the fringes on the wall that's
the explanation that quantum mechanics
gives today so can Niels born his
disciplines answer Saint Thomas Aquinas
regarding whether an angel can be in two
places at once yeah of course there it
is it's called the coherence followed by
superposition so it you know it said two
places then it comes back together and
that's how it produces what is it the
interference fringes what is it
constructive and destructive
interference that's the explanation we
have today from quantum mechanics
because they insist on particles and as
long as they insist on particles they're
gonna have to give you a nonsensical
answer to that to the slit experiment
they say we cannot explain it otherwise
because if if the photon is a particle
or the electron is a particle and it has
to interference to interfere it has to
be to the to have to somehow meet but
how did they meet if they had to go
through these two slits well it's very
easy we do with a magic wand we just say
the particles at two places at once
and that's exactly what st. Thomas
Aquinas said about his angels okay we're
gonna continue on Wednesday with this
and just so you can see how mr. Aquinas
invented quantum mechanics at least all
the arguments that we have all the
explanations and he justified each one
and these guys don't even justify and
they say we can't see in there we don't
know what we're staring at because it's
all invisible and we're gonna insist on
particles because there are particles we
vote for the particle they can't live
without there
articles because particle represents a
value single value that they can put in
equation so they will not be getting rid
of the particle and of course when they
try to give a physical interpretation to
their equations they have to use the
particle and they say well then we have
to use math the magic wand we have to
make the particle do things that we
don't see in our real world and one
thing is for the particle to have
different properties in the invisible
quantum world of mother nature we can
deal with that what we can't deal with
some of the rationality of particle
being at two places at once
virtual particles coming in from the
void from from space making up space
being being the material of which space
is made of you know the ether
essentially and then this particle
disappears and it's undetectable in our
world you know that all they're doing is
putting that all this stuff beyond your
comprehension and they said well you got
to study math to understand what we're
saying you got nothing to do with math
it's a conceptual issue we'll see you on
Wednesday and we're gonna continue and
hopefully finish up with mr. Aquinas if
I don't get too many questions we'll see
you on Wednesday
bye bye